avec environ 200 mille étudiants sur son
territoire l'académie de versailles et
l'une des plus importantes de france
sont cros a dû s'adapter une nouvelle
fois face aux deuxièmes confinement pour
subvenir aux besoins des étudiants
le restaurant du gross de guyancourt est
resté ouvert en vente à emporter avec
des repas en euros pour les boursiers
je trouve ça très intéressant ça
m'arrange manquant même beaucoup puisque
moi j'habite au très loin donc où les
fêtes de préparer chez moi et dvd d'or
parce que moi je travaille à l'abbaye
parce que chez moi y'a pas de connexion
la juste remis en route en fait ce qu'on
avait déjà mis en place
c'est vrai que ça a été toute simple et
oracle puisque quand leur confinement a
été annoncée le jeudi dès le lundi nous
étions en capacité de remettre cette
vente à emporter une adaptation rapide
mais nécessaire contrairement aux
premiers confinement d'un universitaire
est encore longue des étudiants
étrangers ou de province ne sont pas
rentrés chez eux
nous avons beaucoup plus d'étudiants qui
viennent se restaurer lors de ce
retournement par rapport au premier nous
faisons à peu près 50 repas par jour
les étudiants se présente entre 11h30 et
13h30
ils peuvent bénéficier de repas ce
composant donc d'un sachet qui contient
une entrée en plat chaud à consommer
immédiatement et un dessert outre les
restaurants et résidences étudiantes
sont encore occupés un suivi régulier
est effectué par les agents d'accueil
pour déceler les jeunes en difficulté et
mettre en place des aides financières ou
psychologiques rester tout seul dans un
studio 20 mètres carrés c'est quand même
pas forcément facile tout le temps en
fait ils ont un numéro qui peuvent
appeler prendre rendez-vous et
à des créneaux qui leur sont attribuées
pour pouvoir échanger avec un
psychologue sur les difficultés qu'ils
peuvent rencontrer les animations
culturelles en vidéoconférence sont
aussi été maintenue parmi les 132
résidents du bâtiment vauban de
guyancourt deux tiers sont restés sur
place
c'est bien plus que lors du premier
confinement